on the one hand we have Donald Trump
denying that Russia meddled in the 2016
election despite all evidence which we
talked about already on the program on
the other hand you have Trump Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson pointing out that
we're just not at all prepared for
Russia to meddle in the 2018 election
which they're already setting up to do
Rex Tillerson 'he's concern takes it as
a foregone conclusion that Russia
meddled in the 2016 election and he's
focused on 2018
while his boss Donald Trump doesn't even
accept that it happened in 2016 it's
very weird and not only is Rex on saying
that Russia is already trying to
influence the 2018 election he's saying
it's going to be tough to stop them from
doing it recently saying in an interview
with Fox News quote I don't know that I
would say we are better prepared because
the Russians will adapt as well the
point is if it's their intention to
interfere they are going to find ways to
do that we can take steps but this is
something that once they decide they're
going to do it it's very difficult to
preempt it it's not just Tillerson who
believes this CIA director Mike Pompeo
not a bleeding-heart liberal anti Trump
dude recently told the BBC quote I have
every expectation that they will
continue to try and do that we do have
elected officials who understand that
this is a serious thing and then you
have Trump and House Republicans House
Republicans voted last year to eliminate
the only federal agency that prevents
the hacking of voting machines there
used to be an entity called the election
assistance Commission and back in
February of 2017 the House
Administration Committee voted to get
rid of that altogether period it helps
states run elections and it also works
to prevent
election machine hacking they are gone
okay and there are two explanations for
this and neither is good one explanation
is Trump is completely genuine when he
says he doesn't believe Russians
attempted to meddle if that's true if
Trump genuinely doesn't think Russia
tried to meddle that's scary because
it's completely clear at this point and
it's the consensus opinion of the
intelligence community
the other possibility to explain Trump's
ongoing denial of Russian meddling is
actually even worse because it suggests
Tom Trump does believe that Russia
meddled and he wants it to continue
because he either knows or suspects that
had helped him become president of the
United States both disasters in
different ways one is stupidity and the
other is more bordering on treason and I
read this online and thought it was what
was a prescient analogy given what we
have coming up in terms of sporting
events Putin and Trump and Republicans
trying to stop Russian meddling I'm
sorry
putting Trump and Republicans in charge
of stopping Russian meddling in
elections is like putting Russia in
charge of preventing steroid use at the
Olympics it's like the wolf guarding the
henhouse I think would be the most
colloquial analogy I can make how long
is this going to go on at a certain
point when is reality going to be called
reality by the people at the top echelon
of power in the United States I wish I
had an answer I wish it would be like oh
well if maybe if the 2018 omid terms
don't go well the right is going to have
no chance but to sort of acknowledge
reality I think that they can continue
this separation from reality for a very
very long time and it may not have
electoral implications send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by brilliant
which is an amazing website that lets
you engage in fun and interesting
problems and puzzles to learn more about
almost anything related to math science
and engineering it's a vibrant community
of over 5 million members that brings
together expert and the experience of
students and educators and professionals
from all over the world to create a
really interactive learning environment
and learning in the presence of an
actual community really makes a
difference when you use brilliant you're
in the company of over 5 million other
members who share your curiosity and
your love for math and the sciences and
the community at brilliant
portes you're learning you build an
emotional connection with the subjects
that you're learning because you're
interacting with other people learning
the same stuff and that's what sets
brilliant apart from other educational
websites get started immediately by
signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman and the first 200
people who do sign up at brilliant org
slash David Pakman will get 20% off an
annual premium membership sign up
brilliant org forward slash David Pakman